nous sommes presque au nid
qui ressemble à un bébé crime pour sa
maman
et
coupé maintenant c'était une excellente prise
bienvenue au début de la production de
cliff beast six
merci de nous rejoindre dans notre bulle
s'il vous plaît assurez-vous que vous portez correctement
ppe le toucher physique est bien sûr hors de propos,
donc je recommanderais de
faire des yeux doux l'un à l'autre je vais
vous montrer à quoi cela ressemble
c'est tellement excitant c'est comme si mes
affiches de films avaient pris vie
vous apprendrez bientôt à détester ces gens
nous  sont l'un des deux films en production en
ce moment si nous échouons le studio
va tomber je ne suis pas un magicien je sais que
tu n'es pas un [ __ ] de magicien si tu
étais un [ __ ] de magicien tu as sorti un
film de ton cul oh mon dieu  c'est minnie
driver oh je l'aime
ce film va faire oublier au monde
tous leurs problèmes
ce que nous faisons est énervé
c'est du vrai cristal vient de faire un [ __ ] de
tic-tac avec un dinosaure
[Musique]
hé les gars je ne me sens pas si bien  certains d'entre
vous ont été testés positifs pour la grippe lauren
je pense qu'il se passe quelque chose avec lauren qui
est le bon virus
devrions-nous nous inquiéter de
ce niveau de vomi
il y a des conneries vraiment folles en
ce moment
[Musique]
pourquoi ressembles-tu à benedict
cumberbatch en ce moment
je n'aime pas ça arrête d'être
benedict cumberbatch
[musique]
ils nous gardent ici la
merde devient réelle sur les bêtes de la falaise
es-tu nerveux de rencontrer les dinosaures
maman ils ne sont pas réels
je pensais qu'il y avait un éléphant portant
un masque ou quelque chose comme ça
[Musique]
vous